robert spencer will the world remain
united against russia until after the
war ends and afterwards whenever that is
what will the future relationship be
with putin and russia after
they withdraw from ukraine i expect that
this conflict heralds the beginning of a
new cold war and that there will be
tensions between russia and the united
states
for
years maybe decades to come
and that they will be in increasing
competition around the world although
really when we're talking about
competition between the united states
and russia we have to remember that
china has taken over as the primary
economic partner of most of the states
of africa and much of europe and so on
and so they're really the one that we
got to watch out for but
uh for a variety of reasons including
the biden administration's own interests
there that's not happening